[Música]
na aviação
antes de um piloto poder pilotar um
avião de verdade ele tem que acumular
centenas de horas em simuladores
virtuais
na saúde a gente até tenta fazer coisas
parecidas a gente usa imagem vídeo
boneco kobayahi robô ator paciente real
o problema é que nenhuma dessas
ferramentas isoladamente leve sente o
suficiente para que a gente confia nelas
como o método ouro o padrão ouro de
treinamento
o máximo que a gente consegue fazer é
oferecer máximo de ferramentas possíveis
para os profissionais que os estudantes
de saúde e esperar que eles tenham um
desempenho melhor
só que é irreal a gente pensar que as
faculdades no brasil os centros e
hospitais no brasil vão conseguir
reproduzir o que grandes centros aqui em
são paulo fazem por exemplo é o traçado
falar que a educação está ultrapassada e
isso já foi dito aqui hoje a forma como
a gente encara como a gente treina as
coisas
ela tá ela está ultrapassada foi
levantado em duas apresentações atrás da
questão 200 médicos poxa três pessoas
isso significa mais de mil pessoas
morrendo todos os dias em 2015 segundo
aquele estudo da ufmg que foi citado
todos os dias em hospitais privados
a gente nem tem a informação do hospital
público mas a gente não pode se enganar
que isso não é produto da ineficácia do
sistema brasileiro
isso não é um produto nacional nos
estados unidos os livros médicos são a
terceira maior causa de morte
isso se dá principalmente por essas
questões de falta de ferramentas
adequadas como já foi dito várias vezes
aqui hoje para o treinamento desses
profissionais na no fórum econômico
mundial do ano passado se não me engano
foi levantado que 65% das crianças que
estavam entrando na escola naquele ano
vão se formar e vão trabalhar em
empregos que sequer existem como é que a
gente trabalha como é que a gente estuda
e prepara um profissional da saúde para
uns para um cenário desses
é nós acreditamos que as soluções elas
estão elas envolvem tecnologia é uma das
melhores tecnologias que a gente
acredita hoje para trabalhar é
justamente a realidade virtual à
realidade vitória incrível porque antes
o que você via numa tela de computador
agora você veste um óculos coloca uma
luva um controle e você consegue pegar a
interagir com quem está lá dentro a
gente se você consegue participar de um
mundo que antes era entendível e agora
está no universo onde as variáveis são
controlados onde eu consigo modificar
muito bem onde eu consigo avaliar o que
você está desempenhando eu consigo te
colocar em cenários adversos
a gente gosta de pensar lá na la na
média on da seguinte forma é tentando
trazer essa questão de ferramenta não
como um fim mas como meio então
realidade virtual como um meio para
entregar uma mensagem a gente gosta de
tocar no paciente virtual
conforme o paciente virtual avança e se
parece mais com um paciente real
diferentes produtos e aplicações podem
sair desse paciente então num primeiro
momento a gente pode fazer o que a gente
faz uma médium que é treinamento de
estudante de medicina majoritariamente
em para ajudar em disciplinas como
anatomia e fisiologia
nosso objetivo é justamente diminuir
esse espaço que existe entre a teoria ea
prática quando a gente quer deixar o
aluno empoderado ele chegar com uma
prática melhor preparado com o
conhecimento consolidado
só que quando você consegue começa a
pegar informações de pacientes reais por
exemplo universidade de basel fez
eles pegaram um exame de imagem de um
paciente real e colocaram dentro do
ambiente de realidade virtual
isso torna não só mais legal do que
estudar a anatomia do jeito que é hoje
em interativa como que a gente está
fazendo
mas você traz toda aquela discussão de
casos clínicos que os médicos na casa
dos estudantes na casa deve conhecer
muito bem estar prontos patamar agora
você não discute mais aquele modelo
platônico ideal de um paciente saudável
de 25 anos brasileiro caucasiano agora
você discute aquele paciente específico
aquele caso um caso real quanto mais
informações você vai colocando deixando
esse paciente próximo do real mas
aplicações você consegue fazer mais
próximo do tratamento do paciente você
fica
a seu filho nos estados unidos por
exemplo eles pegam os exames de imagem
donde geralmente ele trabalha com câncer
no cérebro então eles pegam esses anos
colocam dentro da realidade virtual
entrega um médico treinar como ele tem
que fazer o procedimento antes de fazer
uma intervenção do paciente e entrega
para o próprio paciente entender como o
que vai ser feito no corpo dele então
médico usa a ferramenta para explicar o
paciente o que vai acontecer mas vamos
ficar aqui só nesse visual na anatomia
das coisas nem não vê as coisas ver as
coisas funcionando
a gente pode usar ferramentas
tecnologias de outras áreas como machine
learning inteligência difícil é
artificial e treinar esse paciente para
ele responder como um paciente real
então imagine um cenário onde a gente
consegue pegar um banco de dados de
informações de pacientes diversos um
número insuficiente que a gente consiga
treinar a máquina a se comportar como um
paciente real
a partir disso a gente consegue não só
fazer aquele treinamento pré cirúrgico
mas a gente consegue literalmente que a
softwares melhores de suporte à decisão
a gente consegue fazer predição dentro
da realidade virtual
hoje se fala muito em modelos de
experimentação e tudo mais ele pode ser
virtual como a china unicom a
inteligência artificial e vou além se o
paciente é tão real quanto se pode ser a
gente começa a prestar atenção nos
outros stakeholders que estão nesses
nesse ecossistema
se eu tenho um paciente e eu tenho um
médico fazendo um procedimento médico
bom eu posso usar um médico que está
fazendo esse procedimento pegar essa
informação e treinar uma máquina para
replicar a informação um outro paciente
que tenha características parecidas e eu
não estou falando isso porque nossa você
é maluco a google de 2015 tentando fazer
isso as coisas elas já estão acontecendo
e as empresas já estão se movendo tudo
que eu mostrei já existe
eu pergunto pra vocês é quantas horas de
experiência o médico tem que ter para
que vocês possam confiar nele nós a
médium a gente acredita que a entidade
virtual ela já não é mais só
indispensável para o treinamento de
alunos de faculdades de medicina por
exemplo mas que ainda vai impactar a
vida de todo mundo aqui obrigado
[Aplausos]